good morning well i was very concerned
to hear these revelations
clearly we'd already seen that sing
report that was just mentioned into
islamophobia within the conservative
party very serious findings within that
report and yet we still don't have the
conservative party
willing to
use the term islamophobia it appeared to
have been banned from
minister scripts so you won't see many
ministers having even used that term
they won't define the term islamophobia
either and now these additional
revelations about the behavior
of government in practice and prime
minister and his chief whip towards a
former
minister so really i think for many
people watching this it just looks like
yet another case where the conservative
government is in disarray where there
are enormous internal problems and of
course this conservative government then
is not getting a grip on the really
important issues that are facing people
not least that cost of living crisis
where we're seeing dither delay and
inaction from the conservatives rather
than the plan to help people that labor
set out
i was listening to michael fabricants
over the weekend i read about it on
twitter also as i saw him speaking on
television uh describing um the minister
or former minister as a mediocre
minister and said that her claim in his
word stinks
because she's not obviously muslim
what should happen to him
well i think action does need to be
taken by the conservative party
obviously those comments were deeply
offensive they're not of uh in any way
the standard one would expect from a
serving member of parliament they're
deeply offensive and i think this just
underlines again the need for the
conservative party the government of
this country to actually start taking
islamophobia
seriously to start acting against
islamophobia and to start acting on all
of the other issues that are facing our
country right now not least that cost of
living crisis that i mentioned before
how seriously does labor take
islamophobia we know that there was
a survey back in 2020 by the labour
muslim network and they don't feel that
the hierarchy within the labour party
treats them well at all
well we've been working extensively with
the labour muslim network
with a variety of different groups to
make sure that we set our house
in order and we've put in for example a
new independent complaints process and
i'm really grateful to those within
labour muslim network who've worked with
us to get that new process put into
place we now have a code of conduct
for labour members on islamophobia as
well so we are acting to make sure that
we have the right systems there we're
not trying to brush
anything under the carpet as the
conservatives seem to want to do we've
taken action we can always improve but
we want to be transparent around it and
i think that's where the big difference
lies where there have been problems
within the labour party we have sought
to take action we've been open about the
need for change unfortunately with the
conservatives they just do not seem to
be willing even to acknowledge that
islamophobia is a problem and as i said
they don't even seem to be willing to
use the term islamophobia even when it
is clearly very present sadly
yeah even but you know let's continue to
shine a light into the murky corners of
uh of the labour party further 60
percent almost of muslim members and
supporters did not feel well represented
by the leadership of the party and 25
percent of them uh said that they
directly experienced islamophobia within
the party what sort of society are we
living in
okay that's why we've been taking action
that report was from a couple of years
ago it doesn't mean that everything is
completely sorted out now we still have
more work to do but it is why we need to
be putting as a party as i said those
new processes
in place has been a huge amount of
change a new code of conduct we're not
going to be saying that the people who
are complaining are the problem which
seems to have been the approach from the
conservative party instead the labour
party saying were there problems let's
sort them out let's do so transparently
let's get a grip on this and stamp out
islamophobia and any form of racism
wherever it exists that's our approach
very different to the conservatives
approach i'm guessing you're referring
there to anti-semitism as well um should
jeremy corbyn who you did work with
there's a shadow treasury minister
should he ever
be readmitted to the labour party after
his suspension over anti-semitism within
the party
well the labour party has taken the
decision to readmit jeremy corbyn under
the complaints process however uh the
the whip so the whipping mechanisms that
everyone has been hearing so much about
over recent days with the conservative
party that whip has not been restored to
jeremy corbyn it's the decision
ultimately for the whip to take we've
been again very open about that what
that process is um and that's where the
situation stands at the moment sure yeah
but that wasn't my question my question
is what do you think
uh well i think you actually asked me
kate whether he should be readmitted
into the labour party
okay he has been he has been
as a member through those processes okay
should he have the whip uh given back to
him then if we're going through
semantics what do you think
well that is a decision for the whips to
take my understanding is that it relates
to um whether there would be compliance
with requests for an apology to remove
material on that kind of thing um i
really really hope that we will see
ultimately engagement you know from all
sides on this and that's all that i'm
going to say on the matter
why why won't you say what you think
um well because ultimately we do use
those processes okay we use those
processes in a clear fair transparent
way and they've got to be fair to
everyone and you know i don't think it's
fair to have a politician pontificating
about something like this we've been
determined to remove that political
interference from our processes it's
very important to us that's why we've
got that new independent complaints
process coming into practice in the
monster camps that's why i'm not going
to pontificate about this
okay you just brought up the whip so
let's let's just uh ask you a final
question on that bullying and blackmail
do you recognize that
well i certainly recognize unfortunately
that it seems to have been taking place
in the conservative party and i think
ultimately we need to see action within
that party both against bullying and
harassment and we need to see action of
course on the issues that are facing our
country they have not adopted labour's
plans to deal with the cost of living
crisis to deal with the fuel uh prices
spiraling they could do that this week
if they got a grip on internal issues
within the conservative party and
actually faced outwards adopt labour's
plans to get those bills down 200 pounds
off the average household bill if they
followed labour's plans there but they
seem to be paralysed from action which
is deeply disappointing
good to talk to you as always annalise
dodds thank you very much thank you